en quatre mois j'ai un fils très les
services vétérinaires de l'abattoir
bigard de cuiseaux en saône et loire
ont
découvert plusieurs choses assez
inquiétante
un moment moi même je ne faisais plus
forcément le lien que l'animal
[Musique]
et pourquoi les rochers lacs à 214 on a
choisi de cibler cet abattoir en
particulier puisque nous avons reçu
plusieurs alertes au sujet de la
production animale pour cet abattoir
pour me faire embaucher j'ai répondu à
une offre d'emploi sur sur internet
j'ai envoyé un cv assez léger donc il y
avait un bac loria et trois expériences
en industrie qui n'avait rien à voir
avec ce type de poste et ensuite j'ai
passé un entretien d'embauché avec le
vétérinaire officiel de l'abattoir mais
a montré un peu le travail que j'allais
potentiellement à faire à l'avenir et à
la fin il m'a demandé si j'avais peur du
couteau si j'avais peur du sang est en
fait c'est sont la seule question qui
m'a posé donc j'ai compris que c'était
un des seuls critères d'embauché le
premier jour de travail j'arrive sur le
parking de l'abattoir et j'entends les
cris des animaux les cris des vaches et
je comprend tout de suite que je me suis
pas trompé d'endroit en fait en tant
qu'agent vétérinaire j'étais affecté à
deux postes le premier c'était le
contrôle des carcasses et des abats et
le deuxième c'est l inspection de
l'abattage rituel vérifier que
l'abattage des animaux se passe
conformément à la réglementation
d'enfiler c'était c'était quand même de
de respecter le travail qu'on commet
donc on m'avait demandé de faire et
ensuite à l'idée c'est aussi de filmer
le l'abattage des animaux hors de voir
aussi des s'il avait des défaillances au
niveau des services vétérinaires et ça
c'est ce que j'ai pu constater pendant
pendant ces quatre
animaux arrivent blessés notamment des
fractures à la jambe et ses animaux
peuvent rester 10 heures sur le site
avant d'être abattu alors que la
réglementation exige que les animaux qui
arrivent blessés qui nous fait passer
déplacés soit abattu le plus rapidement
possible j'ai eu l'opportunité que
d'inspecter l'abattage rituel l'abattage
sans étourdissement puisque dans cet
abattoir l'abattage traditionnelle n'est
pas un sport
allez les animaux qui les vache qui
meugle en sortie de pièges les des
vaches qui relève la tête
on devrait être il faudrait d'urgence
lorsqu'il a repris sa conscience je suis
dénonce tout
va arriver tout et défaillance des
services vétérinaires s'explique pour
plusieurs raisons la première c'est
qu'il n'ya aucune formation des emplois
et des services vétérinaires moi on m'a
donné quelques explications sur le tas
sur le terrain pendant pendant une
semaine ou deux avec des informations
parfois contradictoires
il ya quelques années les soeurs et
ternaires était constitué de 24 agents
vétérinaires et maintenant on était plus
que 15 voire 13 à certains moments donc
il ya eu un gros manque d'effectifs
si c'est vrai ces dernières ne peuvent
pas agir je me demande justement qui
peut agir pour ces animaux a donc me
sens assez impuissant face à la
situation et je reçois aussi beaucoup de
tristesse puisque je suis confronté au
quotidien aux animaux qui sont égorgés
je croisais souvent leurs regards avant
qu'il soit tué c'est un regard qui est
vraiment très difficile à supporter à
soutenir
mais la double
c'est vraiment le regard sur l'exemple
de l'abattoir qui a changé pour moi j'ai
vu des employés qu'il y avait une forte
sensibilité aux animaux mais qui aussi
subissent un peu les conditions de
travail qui subissent le manque
d'effectifs les consignes
contradictoires c'est tout un
environnement qui est complètement
déstructuré qui est complètement
inconfort m'en fait qui n'est pas propre
à au bien-être animal et la fille de
cette enquête l'association l214 a
décidé de porter plainte contre bigarrée
contre l'état et en parallèle lancé une
pétition pour demander l'interdiction de
l'abattage sans étourdissement et
l'interdiction du transport des vaches
gestantes j'espère que cette enquête
permettra aux personnes qui ont le
courage de regarder ses vidéos d'avoir
un nouveau regard sur les animaux de
d'avoir un rapport différent et nord